Sam how are you this morning I'm great
how are you I'm doing okay but big man
on campus here uh anybody there to treat
you like a king oh I i I've just it's
just been support from my from my
teammates friends family it's been it's
been a heck of a time all right before
the advanced you have any idea that
you're going to get to the plate and
have any role in this you know I you
know check its coach Checketts was
telling me like get your bat ready you
know get yourself loose might put you in
and you know I was just ready and when I
went on when I went up on deck I just I
had a ton of things going through my
mind and you know I could really think
about was just just hit something hard
all right so you're facing a pretty good
pitcher there yeah you are you're aware
of that that Zack birdie was what
drafted 26th overall by the White Sox so
you go up to the plate bases are loaded
two outs and take us through what what
you expect and what happened you know I
was expecting him like you know come at
me with fast balls you know trying to
blow that honey my fastball by me but I
just honestly right when I went up there
I just I kind of went blank and just
just tried to do what I've been just try
to do as little as possible you know not
trying to get too big be a short to the
ball as possible and he threw me some in
my wheelhouse and I did as much as i
could with it when do you know it's gone
Sam oh boy right right before I touch
first-base I saw it go over and I just I
threw my hands up and it all went all in
black from there and then you got to
home plate oh wow yeah and then Greg got
jumped on yeah they did they crusher
were you at the bottom of the pile i was
but i think i was so none that i didn't
feel the whole the whole way to the team
on me we also had the umpire Danny
Everett who I think was brought down in
the pile as well you know I didn't I
didn't really see him until I started
watching the videos of it and I
saw him just get absolutely demolished I
feel terrible how many home runs had you
had prior to that this year freshman
year right yeah okay so how many home
runs had you had this year this year I
had one before that so you're not the
you're not the guy most likely to hit a
walk-off grand slam to send his team to
the College World Series uh I guess not
and are you are you third-string catcher
uh yes sir you're not still third string
catcher you got to be elevated a second
string at least now Sam right I mean hey
it's I try to do my part anyway i can
now one of the other reasons why we
wanted to have you on is your musical
taste it's one thing to hit a grand slam
to go to the College World Series but a
couple of guys here that work with me
they I told them the music selection
that you like so run down your favorite
bands here oh boy well my all-time
favorite band has to be Slipknot and you
go to concerts I do I try to go as much
as I can my parents don't really let me
cuz they're kind of afraid but I'm Molly
I'm a big heavy metal fan give me some
of the other bands there that's on the
law flip nod Metallica Lamb of God all
that there you go
this should be your walk up song Lamb of
God there Sam yeah
not exactly family-friendly here that
kind of music Sam uh no it's not quite
as mainstream as theirs most things but
you don't have walk up songs in college
do you we do we have we have walk up
songs at home mine was a slipknot song
did you ever laugh at anybody do you
ever Punk a teammate like even have
something really soft as he went to the
play uh you know in high school I had a
I had a black eyed peas song just for
fun oh yeah but it's changed now now
you're back to heavy metal now you made
it business yes I had to stick to my
route yeah well good luck when you get
to Omaha it's a great story and
something you have the rest of your life
and thanks for joining us Sam hey thank
you guys for having me this was awesome
Sam Cohen you UC Santa Barbara catcher
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience